how was your week - you may have heard
was quite eventful and a message for
Whoopi Goldberg regarding what happened
on the view this week coming up later in
the show but first my open every week I
do an opening statement on whatever it
is that has me fired up this week take a
look the GDP under Obama was barely one
we're going up to four so we hit crime I
also think it's important as we said 89%
the Republican Party still supports him
he still has huge popularity in the
country and if Democrats don't get there
you know what together he's certainly
going for you because I'm not nobody
else oh yeah did you just point at me
listen I don't have Trancas arrangement
let me tell you what I have a lot of I'm
tired of people starting a conversation
with Mexicans or liars and rapist I'm
tired
[Applause]
I'm 62 years old there been a lot of
people in office that I didn't agree
with but I have never ever seen anything
like this I've never seen anybody whip
up such hate I've never seen anybody be
so
and really you don't watch the show so
you don't know that I don't suffer from
that what I suffer from is the inability
to figure out how to fix this that's my
issue but one of the things that you
talk about a lot and I'm curious about
it is the deep state how long is the
deep state been there and who's running
it well I won't answer your question
because you getting statement which was
how horrible it is a Donald Trump be
here murdering the children of Americans
say you know what's hard when the
presidency we're able to beat the hell
out of him after that I was cursed at
and I and my team were thrown out of the
building should I be angry I suppose I
should but in the end this isn't about
me and nobody needs to feel sorry for me
I'm a big girl when I go back in the
view again no one intimidates me but
more on this issue specifically to what
behoove I've known for years later in
the show as I said this isn't about me
there's a bigger issue at play here the
view was just a microcosm of what's
going on in this country the level of
hatred toward the 45th President of the
United States is beyond anything we've
seen in American history he was once an
icon sought after for movies television
by politicians on both sides of the
aisle sports figures and yes even the
media then he ran for president now
Donald Trump is the target of vitriol so
palpable it's simply frightened
frightening and reason has become
irrelevant we can't have conversations
anymore and the ripple is national in
scope family friends acquaintances can't
even talk to each other they remove each
other from Facebook and they change
dinner and family gathering plans for
the holidays depending on the
politics it's almost impossible to have
a rational discussion that doesn't turn
into a food fight and for some it's now
even fashionable to threaten the
President of the United States
he talks how well he wants to punch
people in the face well I'd like to
punch him in the face they asked me
would I like to debate this gentleman
and I said no I said if we were in high
school I'd take you behind the gym and
beat the hell out of them
when was the last time an actor
assassinated the president yes I have
thought an awful lot about blowing up
the White House and that's not all
when a member of Congress can say this
about people who work for and support
the president we have a real problem in
America
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not welcome anymore anywhere the anger
of the lepton America is out of control
when White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders needs Secret Service protection
because she speaks for the President of
the United States something's wrong when
we get screamed at even before we give
an opinion something's wrong but it's
acceptable to shout people down when
it's acceptable to not hear what people
think that's the first step to where we
don't think and thinking you are right
and not allowing debate is fascism
whether it comes from a Democrat or a
Republican or the right for the left
it's wrong it seems in America today
that the takedown of a president is more
important than the success of our nation
I lived through eight years of Barack
Obama a lot of you heard my opens I was
very clear in my objection to his
policies but I never rooted for America
to fail the things that we should all
want and that no one would be against
simply don't matter anymore
minority unemployment the lowest in
history the economy soaring Isis
defeated tax cuts for everyone they
don't seem to matter if it's under this
president some people are even rooting
for an economic collapse is like I feel
like the bottom has to fall out at some
point and by the way I'm hoping for it
because I think one way you get rid of
Trump is a crashing economy so please
bring on the recession sorry if that
hurts people but it's either ruther
recession or you lose your democracy so
to all you on the Left who were
threatening our president shouting down
and even attacking his supporters and
rooting against America
you're kidding yourselves if you think
that what you're doing
standing up for America what you're
doing is tearing down America and when
you do you're tearing down something
more important than even the President
of the United States you're tearing down
the values of the United States itself
everyone has the right to speak but when
you can't even listen to what someone
has to say because you despise the man
who is president you undermine not the
President of the United States you
undermine the United States and that's
my open and that's my open tell me what
you think on my facebook twitter and
instagram hashtag judge Janine